[Music]
some of the best food i had in india
was street food and every little food
stall
was cooking up something spicy something
delicious
a little teaspoon of oil and a toast off
a teaspoon of cumin mustard seeds
a touch of salt and pepper
lightly fry them off it's really
important to cook off the spices
it intensifies the flavor but really
draws out that nice
spicy deep rich flavor so
onion three fingers one in front two
behind
nice and fine
onions in now
we're going to caramelize those onions
mustard seeds have started to infuse
cumin has that nice kick
now with a little touch of butter in
there get it nice and sort of rich
gas up nice and high and really
caramelise those onions now
once the onions have turned a rich
golden color that's what i'm looking for
that is beautiful add baby spinach
keep that pan nice and hot if you don't
cook it out
the actual breakfast ends up watering
when the spinach is cooked set aside and
it's on to the spicy eggs
now the breakfast really starts to come
alight four nice eggs
now give those eggs a little whisk a
little touch
of butter into the pan a little teaspoon
of oil so the butter doesn't burn when
the butter and oil are hot
add a teaspoon of garam masala and
turmeric
cook that out now take your eggs
into the pan
almost going to make like a really nice
spicy scrambled egg
turn the gas down
now as the scrambled egg comes together
just finish that with a little bit of
butter i quite like the sort of
creaminess
makes it so much more delicious
and then from there i get my spinach
chop up and then fold in
the spinach to your scrambled egg
something quite exciting about eating
spice for breakfast
but it's served in these wonderful
little thin naan breads
this will work with any flatbread or
wrap you fancy and then lightly toast
your naan
take the eggs off the heat whilst you
get on with the last job add quick mint
and spice yogurt dressing
couple of tablespoons of fresh yogurt
in there's always something to take out
the heat
then add chopped mint salt and turmeric
mix that in
now take a scrambled egg
and half fill and now
it smells incredible get your yogurt
down on top and lift that over
and for me that's what really stands out
with street food
in india how delicious they can make
street food with a little bit of spice
amazing
[Music]
once you try this spicy wrap i promise
you scrambled eggs will never taste the
same
succulent zingy prawn tostadas wonderful
prawns
gonna marinade them first with a little
bit of garlic
nice and fine and don't worry if you
can't slice thinly just
get a little crater and grate the garlic
nice and fine as well nice
pinch of chili flakes over your prawn
garlic in salt pepper
and olive oil give that a really nice
little mix whilst the prawns marinade
i'm gonna knock up a salad
this is a really nice sort of light
fragrant salad
radishes topped and tailed and then into
quarters
cherry tomatoes halved spring onions
sliced
and seasoned and then just to liven
things up
a little bit of chili in there and slice
them on an angle
now the avocado cut in half
give that a little twist so you just go
down
and down and down carefully with your
knife turn it around
go down and down and down and then
you take your spoon and you've got your
diced avocado
coming out already now baby gem lettuce
half then shred freshly squeezed lime
juice
and a little drizzle of olive oil
tostada is a
classic mexican style
open tortilla so that lime complements
it beautifully
lastly roughly chopped coriander and
give it a mix
that is the perfect base for our tostada
the salad's ready now for the prawns and
don't be afraid
of getting the pan nice and hot
teaspoon of olive oil in
anything less than that sizzle when you
put that first prawn in there
don't put them in keep them nice and
flat
make sure you've got all that marinade
in there as well watch them change color
rapidly i'd rather cook them quicker
in a hotter pan and slower in a colder
pan
the difference in taste is night and day
the prawns will take just two minutes to
cook through
lime juice just over the top nice
toss them over the lime
these are corn tortilla quite robust and
it's a kind of
base that doesn't disintegrate hot pan
in
it's a dry pan so that corn tortilla
goes nice and crispy on the outside
look crispy shell to build them
generous with the salad that base will
stay nice and crisp
next with your prawns i like to keep the
tails
in to the center and lay the round
part of the prawn on the outside and
there we have
a delicious yeah very humble prawn
tostada
you